bonsoir depuis la fin de la guerre
d'algérie vous êtes devenu monsieur le
pen marginale du jeu politique
certes vous êtes président d'une
formation autorisée par le ministère de
l'intérieur le front national mais c'est
une formation qui n'a jamais réussi à
faire entrer le moindre représentant au
parlement
les choses ont changé pour vous depuis
d'abord vous vous êtes fait élire
conseiller d'arrondissement à paris dans
le 20e
ensuite il ya eu ces trois scrutins
locaux dreux aulnay le morbihan dans
chacun des cas les électeurs consultés
ont dans une proportion très
significative répondu à votre appel
alors aujourd'hui vous avez à cause de
cela une existence électorale vous
faites partie de la réalité de la
société française
c'est un fait et c'est pourquoi je vous
ai invité ce soir pour en savoir plus
sur vous pour comprendre et pour aider
les français qui nous écoutent à
comprendre cette invitation vous le
savez ne fait pas plaisir à tout le
monde
il y actuellement devant cette maison
des manifestations le parti communiste
la considère comme indécente et
appellent au boycott l'humanité écrit de
vous cet homme est dangereux parce que
la politique qu'il défend est dangereuse
et le nouvel observateur ajoute qu'il
aurait mieux valu l'ignorer les lettres
que nous recevons en porte témoignage
monsieur le pen vous fait peur à
l'origine de cette peur la façon dont
vous parlez de la présence des goethe et
étrangers qui vivent en france et de
leur statut
on connaît de vous vos affiches 20
millions de chômeurs ce sont 20 millions
d'immigrés de 2 millions de chômeurs
pardon ce sont deux millions d'émigrés
de trop c'est un slogan d'exclusion que
vous ont complété par un autre la france
et des français d'abord alors qui êtes
vous vraiment monsieur le pen que voulez
vous est ce que vous êtes le même homme
que celui qui il ya 28 ans et est élu
député poujadiste était partisan de
l'algérie française est ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui les mêmes soutient les mêmes
amis les mêmes idées ou bien ce que vous
avez changé au fil des ans connaissez la
règle de notre mission ce n'est pas une
émission c dans une tribune c'est une
émission de questions sans complaisance
deux réponses sans discours alors ce
soir vous allez affronter pendant un
quart d'heure chacun alain duhamel
jean-louis servan-schreiber pdg de
l'expansion et albert du roy
vous aurez donc une heure pour répondre
sur tous les grands problèmes qui
intéressent les français et nous allons
commencer tout de suite parlé asvp pour
la première question lors jean louis le
scène y at il des questions
oui jean marie le pen bonsoir beaucoup
d'appels téléphoniques ce soir svp mais
pas toujours pour poser des questions de
nombreux téléspectateurs veulent
simplement vous encourager notamment
pour vos prises de position sur
l'immigration mais beaucoup plus
nombreux sont les téléspectateurs ce
soir ce qui condamne formellement votre
action facisme racisme antisémitisme
sont les deux adjectifs qui reviennent
le plus souvent dans les fiches
cela dit plusieurs téléspectateurs vous
demande si vous êtes favorable au
rétablissement de la peine de mort pour
quelques rimes et que pensez-vous du cas
barbie je suis très heureux de pouvoir
répondre aux questions qui me sont
posées encore que il en comporte
plusieurs premières le fascine le
racisme l'antisémitisme ça tout cela
c'est ce qui met en général reprocher
par la presse communiste et celle qui
lui est directement lié cela fait partie
de la désinformation dont le communisme
est en quelque sorte habitués auquel il
est habitué et je n'aurai pas de peine à
me débarrasser du masque que l'on
applique sur le visage puisque
l'occasion m'est donnée dans cette
émission d'être en quelque sorte au
réservoir est ce en relation la question
qui vous a été posée et précise
êtes vous pour le rétablissement de la
peine de mort et pourquoi une partie
parce que je pensais qu'il va les suivre
tout le reste on revient dans la saisie
je suis effectivement un partisan de
lapine de la peine demain et je suis
partisan de l'application de la peine de
mort parce qu' un certain nombre
d'arguments été avancée pour l'abolition
de la peine de mort en particulier celui
selon lequel ne serait pas dissuasive
or en effet elle n'est pas dissuasive
quand elle n'est pas appliquée et je
considère
que la faveur qui est fait actuellement
au criminel aux assassins est quelque
chose de ce qui est extrêmement choquant
pour le pays et de choquant pour la
justice pour en tous les cas les crimes
ignobles que sont les assassinats
d'enfants pour les crimes terroristes
pour les assassinats de policiers je
pense que il est nécessaire de rétablir
la peine de mort elle est en quelque
sorte la clé de voûte de notre système
pénal et si elle est supprimée comme
elle est supprimée et comme sont
supprimés d'ailleurs immédiatement
derrière elle deux des peines les plus
graves du code pénal c'est à dire la
détention à perpétuité et la détention
même à 20 ans puisque chacun sait qu'un
criminel un assassin condamné à mort qui
serait exécutée sous l' empire des lois
d'autrefois est aujourd'hui condamnée en
fait un enfer que douze ou treize ans
ceci est à mon avis extrêmement choquant
et témoigne je le pense très sincèrement
de la décadence de nos institutions de
notre morale publique et de l'incapacité
des dirigeants de notre société à faire
face à l'aspiration la plus fondamentale
de notre peuple qui est l'aspiration à
la sécurité première des libertés
alors tout de suite un quart d'heure de
face à face avec alain duhamel qui va
venir s'asseoir devant vous vous aviez
une autre question
jean-louis les scènes ont conduit à bien
m'entraîner
vous n'avez pas répondu sur le cas
barbie en tout cas va revivre écouter le
cas barbie ne m'intéresse pas plus
qu'ils n'intéressent tous les autres
français et je voudrais dire à cette
occasion combien je suis scandalisé en
ce qui me concerne de voir que à la
télévision dans des émissions où je ne
suis pas présent d'ailleurs mon nom ma
photographie sont très souvent associées
à des défilés de l'armée allemande ou à
ta photo d'hitler ou à d'autres
photo du même genre je dis que cela est
scandaleux comme sont scandaleuses les
manifestations qui s'abrite derrière le
souvenir des morts pour la france ou des
morts en déportation
jean marie le pen n'a strictement rien à
voir avec tout cela est le nom de le pen
est inscrit sur le monument aux morts de
la trinité sur mer
alors celui de georges marchais n'ai
jamais été inscrit que sur les fiches de
paye
augsbourg de lusine messerschmidt
pendant la guerre non monsieur le pen on
peut peut-être s'interroger et là on
rejoint les manifestations qui ont lieu
actuellement dans la rue peut-être
s'interroger sur les raisons pour
lesquelles votre nom est effectivement
associé à ce que vous dites mais céline
question il ya une question qui m'est
posée par les étudiants juifs qui sont
là devant dans la rue et du qui
représente le betar de france est ce par
hasard que les éditions la serpe dont
vous êtes le propriétaire diffuse des
chants nazis des discours et des
portraits d'hitler bon premier point je
suis un des rares hommes politiques qui
gagne sa vie dans la vie professionnelle
ordinaire c'est-à-dire que pour gagner
ma vie j'ai fondé une entreprise
d'édition
je suis à ce titre un éditeurs
phonographiques
je suis spécialisé dans l'édition des
documents sonores et en particulier de
tout ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est
produit dans l'histoire du monde de
l'europe et de la france depuis 40 ans
pratiquement qu'il y à du son c'est si
vrai que d'ailleurs votre maison et
toutes les chaînes de télévision toutes
les chaînes de radio sont mes clients
habituels parce que pour pouvoir éviter
ces disques plus de 120 disques 30 cm
consacrés soit à l'histoire soit au
document sonore soit au folklore
politique et sociale j'ai dû réunir
beaucoup de documents et il est évident
que quand on est un éditeur et un
éditeur libre c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne se
soumet à aucune pression
on donne de la du passé historique de
l'europe de la france et du monde
une image qui est réel il est vrai donc
j'ai publié des disques consacrés au
troisième rech
j'ai consacré aussi de trois disques à
l'histoire d'israël à lénine à hitler à
churchill à mitterrand aa pompidou 12 ou
13 disque à de gaulle à pétain
c'est c c'est à dire que j'ai fait mon
métier d'éditeur et jeu j'affirme que je
ne me soumettrai à aucune dépression qui
prétendrait me dicter dans ce domaine ce
qui est ma loi déontologique j'ajoute
que seul un de ses disques qui affirmait
dans quatre lignes dont j'étais
militaire mais non l'auteur mais que je
prendrai à mon compte que le parti
national socialiste allemand était
arrivé au pouvoir à la suite d'élections
libres ce que nous conte est strictement
aucun historien sérieux
j'ai été condamné pour cela n'est ce pas
j'ai été persécuté je le dis très
franchement et en appel j'ai fait citer
25 témoins sur ces 25 témoins deux
seulement n'ont pas déféré à cette
invitation il y avait cinq généraux de
la deuxième guerre mondiale
cinq des portes est célèbre dans le
président andré marie cinq historiens
bref des gens de qualité
ces 23 d'entre eux ont affirmé qu'ils
étaient de mon droit le plus strict et
il ajouterait pour certains de mon
devoir de faire les publications que
j'ai fait en la forme où je les ai fait
et par conséquent dans ce domaine je ne
regrette rien j'ai fait mon métier
alors alain duhamel ont monsieur le pen
vous avez deux images il ya une première
image qui vous colle à la peau depuis 30
ans depuis vos débuts dans la vie
politique et qui est l'image d'un
extrémiste et d'un activiste et puis il
ya une seconde image que vous essayez
visiblement d'accréditer en ce moment et
à travers laquelle vous vous présentez
comme un homme d'opposition de droite
nationale respectable et légaliste
pour moi ce que je voudrais c'est
pendant ce quart d'heure quand on va
passer ensemble s'il vous poser toute
une série de petites questions précises
auxquelles vous pourrez répondre à votre
tour brièvement première question est ce
que vous vous considérez comme un
démocrate
oui certainement et je le démontre et en
participant à la vie publique de notre
pays en toute circonstance et bien
souvent condamnés à l'avance par le
système électoral majoritaire sans
espoir et j'ai même argumenté bien
souvent contre certaines écoles
philosophiques de droite
qui conteste la démocratie comme moyen
de gouvernement et j'ai dit je suis dans
le fond un démocrate churchill lien
c'est à dire que je me réfère au fameux
aphorisme de churchill dix ans la
démocratie ce branchement un très
mauvais système je n'en connais pas
d'autre alors vous accepter sans réserve
les institutions de la vème république
je parle pas du détail naturellement aux
institutions mais les institutions de la
vème république et le principe de
l'alternance et de la présence de la
gauche au pouvoir
absolument oui sans la moindre accroc du
mans absolument et j'ajouterais même une
chose c'est qu'alors que l'idée qu'il
fallait interdire le parti communiste
légalement en quelque sorte est partagé
par un certain nombre d'hommes
politiques français pas seulement à
droite
moi j'ai toujours pensé que le parti
communiste n'avait pu progresser et
atteindre le niveau qu'il avait atteint
chez nous que parce qu'il n'avait jamais
été réellement combattu sur le plan
idéologique je pense que dans un pays
civilisé évoluer comme le nôtre le la
place du parti communiste devrait être
celle qui l'a ans aux états unis en
angleterre en allemagne c'est à dire
entre 2 et 3%
et j'affirme qu'il est possible à
condition qu'on le combattent sur son
terrain sur le terrain de l'idéologie
quand le dépouillent des privilèges qui
lui ont été concédés depuis 35 ans et je
pense que cela c'est une bataille qui
est en cours actuellement
alors puisque vous êtes favorable à la
démocratie vous le dites vous êtes donc
opposé à toute forme de violence
quelconque dans un pays comme la france
est dans un pays démocratique
j'en suis j'y suis d'autant plus
opposées que j'en suis généralement la
victime
et chaque fois que l'on associe le nom
du front national à la violence c'est la
violence qui lui est fait d'ailleurs
c'est si vrai que aucune instance
judiciaire n'a été engagée ni n'a abouti
à des condamnations de membres du front
national en revanche j'ai été l'objet de
plusieurs attentats terroristes n'est ce
pas j'ai perdu un oeil à la suite donc
pas une bagarre électorale voyons je
veux mener campagne électorale j'ai été
attaqué par des des nervis qui m'ont
jetée à terre désorbiter l'oeil etc
et bien je je je suis je vois
aujourd'hui que je m'exprime à la
télévision
et qu'il faut pour cela constitue et la
télévision en fort chabrol parce qu'il y
a paraît-il des manifestants qui
prétendent par la force et par la
violence m'interdire de m'exprimer
bon donc vous êtes contre ceux qui à
travers des services d'ordre et à
travers la force de leurs muscles tente
d'empêcher des élections de se dérouler
régulièrement absolument bon alors et
expliquez moi brièvement naturellement
pourquoi dans ces conditions vous avez
manifesté disons du respect et de la
sympathie pour franco et disons de la
compréhension pour pino chez comment
est-ce que c'est compatible avec ce que
vous venez de le dire d'abord je met you
man bruit très brièvement
j'ai en effet dit qu'en ce qui concerne
le chili allende et le gouvernement
marxiste qui ne représentaient que 20 à
25 % des voix avait conduit le pays sur
la voie du désastre économique et d'une
révolution qui menaçait d'être sanglante
et j'ai dit que dans ce cas je
comprenais l'action de l'armée chilienne
réalisé d'ailleurs sous la direction
d'un ami allende et d'un de ses anciens
ministres
le général pinochet il n'en a pas dit
plus est d'accord que le président
allende avait été élu le plus
régulièrement du monde
il avait été élu en effet mais il
essayait comme dans d'autres pays
d'imposer la création d'une révolution
marxiste visiblement contre l'opinion de
l'immense majorité et j'ajoute qu'au
moment où les événements du chili se
déroule le président allende a été mis
hors la loi par les assemblées parlement
et franco le général franco est arrivé
au pouvoir vous le savez à la suite
d'une très grave guerre civile et il l'a
fait dans son pays
je pense qu'ils étaient très arriérée
progressé 1,1 dans l'ordre et ramener en
quelque sorte à la paix civile
un pays qui avait été profondément
déchiré j'ai souvent entendu des amis
espagnols de gauche et anti franquiste
me dire combien ils craignaient le
départ du général franco
et peut-être la possibilité de revenir à
des violences très sanglantes comme
celles de 36 je me félicite que la mort
du général franco est abouti à
l'institution d'un régime monarchique et
démocratique mais vous ne considérez pas
que le général pinochet
franco et étaient des démocrates selon
votre coeur certainement pas mais
personnellement je pense que les
gouvernements militaires ne peuvent
s'ils viennent au pouvoir que deux
doivent rester qu'à très peu de temps
juste le temps parfois nécessaire pour
éviter la guerre civile ou pour sauver
le peuple dont ils ont tout de même là
la vie quelque sorte et la pérennité en
garde mais je suis partisan d'un
gouvernement civil
je le dis de la manière la plus claire
et n'est jamais seul est mon opinion sur
ce sujet
quelle est votre réaction quand à une
réunion publique récente à laquelle vous
vous trouviez qui se déroulait à lyon
une de vos vice présidente a parlé de
simone veil en l'appelant la tricoteuse
de giscard oui c'est une image
cet accord qu'elle a dit oui c'est oui
absolument absolument elle l'a dit c'est
une image je dirais oratoire et chaque
chose doit être jugé est ce qu'elle vous
choque
chaque chose doit être jugé dans son
contexte et il est évident que madame
biogaz vice présidente du front national
dont les positions sont très connus sur
la lutte pour en faveur de la vie et
contre la légalisation de l'avortement a
voulu en quelque sorte souligné d'une
manière pittoresque et qui tente si
j'ose dire le rôle joué par madame veil
dans la définition de ces lois tu as
voulu mais ça ne vous savez ça ne vous
choque pas seulement pittoresque écouter
écouter le peuple française nombreuses
et les gratuitement l'été de bourgeois
de salon n'est ce pas et dans les
grandes salles populaires quand on
s'adresse au peuple
on lui parle son langage et ce langage
ne semble pas dans les cases ce langage
ne semble pas en tous les cas avoir
choqué les gens qui assistaient et il y
avait là toutes sortes de gens et
consolider universitaire personnellement
pas utilisé cette image est sans doute
de ne l'utiliserai ge pas bon mais je
trouve que c'était vraiment un point de
détail
bon c'est peut être un point de détail
mais alors pour élargir la question en
ce moment là quand vous rencontrez
autour de vous comme ça arrive à tout le
monde et notamment ce moment des
manifestations d'antisémitisme france
quelle est votre réaction sincère je ne
rencontre pas de manifestations
d'antisémitisme
je rends compte en revanche des
manifestations qui meurent et put
antisémite ce qui n'est pas donné la
région je ne viens du bassin ans annette
ce n'est pas ma question
non vous êtes d'accord c'est quand vous
disons si ça n'est pas autour de vous
quand vous lisez
des propos qui sont antisémites ou quand
vous entendez des propos qui sont
antisémites
je vous dis pas quand vous les prononcer
quand vous les entendez quelle est votre
réaction
autrement dit qu'est ce que vous pensez
de l'antisémitisme écoutez je l' ai déjà
dit plusieurs fois mais je leur dis
n'est ce pas si l'antisémitisme consiste
à persécuté les juifs à raison de leur
religion ou de leur race je ne suis
certainement pas un antisémite il
attribue une tribune juive noter qu'en
trente ans de vie publique
on a pu relever une seule déclaration
antisémite à mon encontre
en revanche je ne crois pas pour autant
obligé d'aimer la loi veil -le d'admirer
la peinture de chagall ou d'approuver la
politique demeure défense voilà quelle
est ma poésie bien
enfin bien c'est une manière de pompiers
bien sûr je réponds à votre question
autrement dit je ne crois pas que comme
le président giscard d'ettajdid ailleurs
que ça me choque de déclarer que en
revenant d'israël je ne reviens pas de
l'étranger par exemple et et quand quand
la même personne au même endroit dans le
même discours parlé des hôpitaux et des
hôpitaux où ils jouent bien et de
l'interruption de grossesse aux pompes
poète qu'hypocrite disons de
l'avortement en comparant sa des fours
crématoires est ce que ça vous semblez
pas avoir des connotations au moins je
pense que l'assassinât massif de
d'enfants dé les photos que l'on a pu
voir correspondent en effet à une forme
de génocide et je conseille considérez
vous savez comment les foetus sont on
les fait disparaître dans les hôpitaux
eh bien on les brûle dans des fours
crématoires c'est comme ça disons que
l'a7 l'association de ce genre d'image à
quelqu'un comme simone veil ne vous
choque pas mais écoutez je n'ai pas de
complexe mois dans ce domaine je
m'exprime librement mais je vais y est
question est jeune et je n'ai pas de
combler et je ne
nan mais pas je le dis très franchement
le terrorisme intellectuel que l'on fait
peser dès que l'on touche à un certain
nombre de problèmes comme celui par
exemple de l'immigration en belgique
geona amouyal à la seconde vague
j'y viens à la seconde près de
l'immigration il ya eu il ya quelques
semaines une déclaration très importante
de l'épiscopat français sur les
problèmes de l'immigration et les
évêques de france collectivement on
expliqué je résume en substance
naturellement l'ont expliqué qu'il
fallait accueillir fraternellement dans
la communauté française les immigrés qui
choisissait de vivre dans notre pays
j'ai les évêques de france
conditionneront choisir je ne reçois pas
mes leçons politiques de l'assemblée des
évêques de france remet vite tout de
suite non mais je vous donne rendez vous
demain je vous demande je vous demande
d'y réagir pas a réagi ces jeunes ans
rejoint jeunes en remontre pas à mon
curé menem point beaucoup que dans le
domaine où je suis spécialiste les curés
mormons et maintenant je suis tout à
fait d'accord sur le problème je ne vous
demande pas de dire que les évêques ont
raison je vous demande de réagir à ce
que les évêques ont dit qu'est ce que
vous jean marie le pen penser de ce que
les évêques ont dit bon écoute et je
pense que les évêques se mêle de ce qui
ne les regarde pas et ils ont en effet
pour devoir de rappeler quels sont les
préceptes évangéliques
c'est à dire de rappeler aux hommes
qu'ils ont entre eux quel qu'il soit une
fraternité des évêques n'ont pas dit en
disant cela d'ailleurs qu'il n'existait
pas de nationalité qu'il n'existait pas
de régimes privilégiés et en particulier
dans la nation dans toutes les nations
en faveur des nationaux et puisque l'on
parlait beaucoup tout à l'heure de
racisme il ya un racisme mois que
j'exècre encore plus que tous les autres
c'est le racisme anti français c'est
celui qui tente à faire à considérer les
français dans leur propre pays comme des
gens dans le fond qui n'aurait même pas
les mêmes droits que les autres et en
particulier que ceux qui se sont très
souvent borné à pousser la porte pour
rentrer c'est à dire ce qu'on avait fait
venir aussi
mais alors là je suis tout à fait à
l'aise pour en parler car j'ai condamné
en son temps les initiatives du
gouvernement français et d'un certain
patronat français en soulignant bien que
en faisant venir des travailleurs
immigrés de basse qualification on le
faisait en fait pour faire peser à la
baisse
sur les salaires manuel et que cette
politique aboutit chez nous a empêché la
revalorisation du travail manuel la
réhabilitation du travail manuel et la
nécessaire modernisation de notre h 30
alors alors mais je la considérais donc
que c'était une faute politique
en même temps qu'une faute économique
alors monsieur le pen est est ce que
quelquefois seul avec vous même si j'ose
dire vous ne vous posez pas la question
de savoir si vous n'êtes pas un petit
peu un apprenti sorcier c'est à dire si
en tenant des propos de ce genre vous ne
déclenche et pas chez des gens en plus
simple que vous des réactions qui elles
sont du racisme au fond est ce que dans
ce cas là vous ne quand vous entendez
parler de racisme et là ne me dites pas
que vous ne m'entendez pas parler est-ce
que vous ne vous sentez pas une part de
responsabilité ce qu'ils m'entendent et
ceux qui m'écoutent peuvent témoigner
que j'ai toujours dit que la politique
que je souhaite voir appliquer à l'égard
de l'immigration étrangère c'est-à-dire
l'inversion du courant de l'immigration
doit se dérouler dans des conditions de
dignité humaine d'ailleurs cela soulève
ne soulève aucune difficulté dans les
publics qui sont très souvent composé de
français d'origine noirs ou d'origine
africaine union africaine ou de deux
ressortissants des territoires
d'outre-mer
carmat de la définition que nous donnons
au front national des français et la
définition de notre nationalité mais il
est évident que quand certains
éditorialistes de radio par exemple
déclare sur le ton de la rigolade à
leurs interlocuteurs allons monsieur
faure 4 j'espère que vous n'êtes pas
comme jean marie le pen que ne voulait
pas mettre les immigrés sur des bateaux
pour l'écouler au milieu de la
méditerranée
je dis que ce sont des gens comme ça qui
crée le racine dans notre pays et qui
incitent à la haine et à la violence des
communautés les unes contre les autres
mais c'est le pen je vais passer à
l'opposition maintenant mais pour que
les choses soient bien claires quand il
ya des réactions de racisme comme elle
existe chez des gens qui sont
quelquefois des gens simples et pas
forcément des gens comme vous ont fait
des études supérieures
vous ne vous sentez jamais à cause des
propos que vous tenez où des propos que
tiennent vos lieutenants ou des propos
de vos militants
une part de responsabilité jamais vous
avez vous en a conscience
il a la grande responsabilité dans cette
affaire serait de ne pas dire la vérité
sur la menace fondamentale qui pèse déjà
sur les budgets sociaux et nationaux de
notre pays au détriment des français
mais qui pèse dans l'avenir sur la
véritable vague déferlante de
l'immigration en provenance du
tiers-monde vers un pays comme le nôtre
frappé par la biais natalité deux pays
qui sont à la fois pauvre et connaissent
une véritable explosion démographique je
pense nos réserves et ce sont les
champions je crois que ce sont les gens
qui veulent fermer les yeux
oui qui veulent frapper cette question
de tabous qui porte la responsabilité
des conséquences raciste de cette
politique et non pas ceux qui sonnent
l'alertent monsieur le pen je pense que
vous y reviendrez eu dans la suite de
l'émission
comment est ce que vous considérez que
aujourd'hui vous et votre mouvement vous
représentez dans l'opinion
quels chiffres vous fixez vous pour les
élections européennes
et combien sont des questions vous y
répondez d'un chiffre à chaque fois et
combien de militants revendiqués vous
que des jeux je crois que il y
actuellement une véritable
transformation qui se produit dans la
société politique française
l'esprit public et est en train de se
mobiliser à un point je suis frappé
d'ailleurs de voir à quel point
l'aveuglément des milieux politiques les
maîtres répondait comme je vois qu'on
arrive à la fin de période
répondez précisément je vous ai demandé
à combien estimez vous votre influence
aujourd'hui quels objectifs vous donnez
vous pour les élections européennes
combien revendiquez-vous 2010 proche je
pense que nous sommes aux alentours de
10%
s'il y avait des élections actuellement
s'il y avait des élections nationales se
déroulant au scrutin proportionnel
ac c'est à dire sans que joue la fameuse
règle des buts utiles les élections
européennes aux élections de la peine je
pense que nous serons entre 10 et 15% et
j'espère faire un score supérieur à
celui du parti communiste et le nombre
de vos militants
nombre de militants je pense une
vingtaine de milliers qui ne cesse de
grandir et r lapointe et en 80 il avait
combien futur ou y en avait beaucoup
moins il y en avait peut-être je ne sais
pas
deux ou trois mille markovic s2a moi il
ya un mois europe numéro 1 vous avez dit
10000 non non
si vous avez dit oui mais vous savez
j'ai vous pouvez venir dans nos bureaux
vous verrez que nous recevons vraiment
massage ou moins un mois et est encore
et encore et encore les gens ignorent
que nous nous trouvons 11 rue bernouilli
dans le 8ème en sommes et nous serons
encore plus garantis que je vous
garantis que là c'est par milliers et
dizaines de milliers sur le pen deux
dernières questions très court oui
la première vous me répondez si vous
voulez si vous voulez pas vous me
répondez pas d'ailleurs je vous ans est
capable donc vous faites ce que vous
voulez pour qui est ce que vous avez
voté au premier et au second tour des
élections 80 j'ai voté au premier tour
je n'ai pas voté je me suis abstenu au
second et au second tour j'ai demandé
d'ailleurs publiquement que l'on veut ta
pour jeanne d'arc et au 1er tour vous
n'avez pas voté vous regrettez pas
possible de dire pourquoi
après parce que je me suis trouvé jeu on
m'a mis dans l'obligation de ne pas
pouvoir me présenter comme candidat vous
n'avez pas pu vous présenter absolument
est ce qu'il ya un homme politique de
l'opposition qui sont de niveau national
qui à vos yeux soient plus à droite que
vous sur l'échiquier
et quel est parmi les leaders de
l'opposition républicaine
celui dont vous vous sentez à votre
guise le plus proche où le moins éloigné
je ne cette question je ne suis
incapable d'y répondre parce que je
considère qu'il ya une solidarité dans
la politique qui a été menée sous la
vème république par l'opposition
libérale par l'opposition parlementaire
et que soit qu'ils étaient au
gouvernement ou qu'il n'y ait pas été la
majorité libérale à appuyer toute la
politique française que j'ai condamné en
disant qu'elle faisait avec les voix de
la droite
la politique de la gourmande autrement
dit pour vous valéry giscard d'estaing
raymond barre jacques chirac simone veil
c'est bonnet blanc et blanc bonnet non
pas tout à fait il y a des positions de
certains d'entre eux ces vidéos je
soigne et qu'il soit le moins élevé nos
tribuns ça dépend parce que sur le plan
politique quelquefois certains sont plus
proches de moi sur le plan personnel et
sentimental je m'en trouve plus
éloignées il m'est difficile de faire
verdi ce genre
de calcul au demeurant je crois que ça
n'a pas beaucoup d'importance à la
duhamel merci svp d'autres questions oui
toujours beaucoup de questions ici svp
question d'un employé de dents que
pensez-vous de l'emprunt fait par la
france à l'arabie saoudite de 4 millions
de dollars que pensez vous de toutes les
banques arabes installés à paris qui
offre du travail aux français
je pense que la politique d'endettement
du gouvernement français est une
politique dramatique et nous sommes
actuellement dans une situation telle
que dans et déjà l'avenir de notre pays
est compromis car nous arrivons au stade
où nous sommes obligés d'emprunter pour
payer les intérêts de nos emprunts
précédents et le gouvernement agit comme
agissent souvent les municipalités
socialistes ou communistes surtout quand
elles savent qu'elles vont perdre les
élections prochaines
elle engage par des emprunts massifs la
politique de l'avenir de et elle espère
qu'un si ce qui leur succéderont dans le
cadre d'une alternance démocratique ne
pourront pas faire face aux obligations
qu'ils ont contractées bon jean-louis
servan-schreiber on va peut-être
poursuivre des assauts ce terrain un
directeur pdg de journal économique
l'expansion pour un quart d'heure
ensuite cela dit il faut tout de même
fait remarquer que sur l'endettement
extérieur c'était largement commencé
sous le gouvernement précédent je le
sache et que lui-même est énormément
aggravée depuis mais j'ai jugé fait je
vous ferai la même réponse que j'ai fait
j'ai critiqué la politique socialisante
des gouvernements prétendument libéraux
avant 1980 vous avez déclaré le 3
décembre au figaro magazine
si l'on me traite de raciste j'attende
des procès et je les gagne tout c'est
exact
oui c'est exact vous en avez une
expérience personnelle je compte tout à
fait j'ai été condamné personnellement
non pas sur le fond mais pour injure
laisse pas il faut savoir que la
législation française se prononce sur le
fait que le mot raciste est une injure
et la cour ajoute que dans ces cas là
elle n'a pas à savoir
si les faits sont réels ou non vous avez
mal lu le jugement
vous êtes un bon économiste sans doute
mais un mauvais juristes c'était un fait
mieux tout à l'heure vous avez dit que
en 30 ans de carrière politique vous
n'aviez pas été amenée à prononcer de
propos antisémites je cite monsieur
mades france
vous n'ignorez pas que vous cristallisée
sur votre personnage un certain nombre
de répulsion patriotique et presque
physique
c'était à la tribune de l'assemblée
nationale en février 58 vous ne pensez
pas que ce sont des propos antisémites
se tenait d'abord je crois d'abord à la
politique de pierre mendès france
politique qui avait abouti à la hune
coisy capitulation en indochine à
l'abandon des populations en particulier
du tonkin et du nord de l'anam qui nous
avait fait confiance et l'autre partie
relève plutôt de l'esthétique voyez vous
je ne pense pas que le président wade
france et jamais rêvé de passer pour un
adonis
je note que vous ne pensez pas que ses
propos sont antisémites
je me permets de citer autre chose quand
je vois les arabes
avec leur allure avachi je me demande
s'il n'y a pas un déterminisme
biologique qui joue à ma connaissance
vous n'avez pas attaquer les auteurs de
deux livres dans lequel s'est produit
atteindrait cette phrase d'un livre de
grégory de pondre un homme de droite
ah oui oui c'est un homme que j'ai c'est
un homme que j'ai qui a tenu dans mon
bureau
trois minutes car le temps qu'il a fallu
pour se présenter et le temps que je lui
indique la porte pour sortir il n'a donc
pas pu relever une seule déclaration de
moins car ils prétendaient me dicter les
termes de son interview je comprends ça
a été repris par monsieur serge dumont
ultérieurement dans un livre qui
s'appelle les brigades noir je voulais
vous le signaler
je constate et seulement vous n'aviez
pas attaquer les auteurs de ces délits
or mon dieu je vais tellement de procès
que déjà généré je ne peux pas attaquer
tout le monde je vais encore être
obligés d'attaquer la télévision
française etc
mais les avocats vous savez non non non
non nous allons en cassation je crois
oui bien sûr mais ils ont mais nous
pouvons donc nous avons l'occasion de
nous retrouver
plus près de nous je si demain les
immigrés s'installeront chez vous
mangeront votre souper coucheront avec
votre femme votre fille ou votre fils ça
a été reproduit la suite de votre
campagne dans le morbihan dans le figaro
et là que je sache je n'ai pas attaqué
j'ai c'est que ce que ses propos disant
viril ronde de choquant quand c'est
regarder à la loupe dans les salons
parisiens chez les gens de qualité salon
les millions de gens même cette affreuse
qu'on peut dire et il est bien évident
que quand je et c'est le rôle d'un homme
politique
le la politique c'est un art de
communication c'est ça consiste à
traduire les aspirations populaires dans
des formes qui soit je dirais gouverneur
gouvernement allemand possible et c'est
aussi ça consiste aussi à traduire les
la gravité des problèmes politiques dans
des termes qui soit compréhensible par
tous or comment décrire autrement
la véritable invasion qui est en train
de se produire dans notre pays la
constitution de véritables villes
étrangères
imperméable à l'autorité au fisc à la
police et cette invasion je ne sais pas
comment dire cela autrement qui ne cesse
de croître
comment expliquer aux gens quel les
menaces dans l'essence même de leur
liberté de l'ordre d'une note que vous
ne considérez pas que ces propos ont une
teneur raciste mais non je ne pense pas
non non non non ils sont contredits par
tellement de déclaration explicite sur
le fait que je considère tous les
français sans distinction de race de
couleur et de religion comme des frères
entendant la nation que je crois qu'il
ne peut pas y avoir d'équivoque
j'ai d'ailleurs précisé
en outre que je ne suis pas xénophobes
que le fait que j'aime mieux les
français et la france n'indique pas pour
autant que je déteste les étrangers ni
que je déteste les autres pays ce que
cela soit soit de ds vous remercie de me
donner l'occasion de le dire de manière
très nette je vous donne l occasion de
préciser encore votre pensée je cite au
cours de l'histoire deux peuples ont
prétendu appartenir à une race
supérieure les juifs et des allemands
pour les uns et les autres
la fère s'est mal terminée autrement dit
nazisme et judaïsme
c'est à peu près qu'il sait cette phrase
est extraite de quel ouvrage elle est
extraite de votre propre hebdomadaire
rlp hebdo du 30 juin 83 riz sous la
signature d'andré figueras écoutez
monsieur figueras qu'il faut autant
demander raison bien parce que vous êtes
de croire même responsable de cette
publication et je voulais savoir
simplement si vous étiez d'accord ou un
désaccord avec cette affirmation
écoutez je n'avais pas lu l'article de
monsieur figueras mais il n'est pourtant
pas très épais mais oui c'est vrai c'est
vraiment pas de chance et chante ses
tâches c'est un journal de pauvres je
vous la corde
bien que la question de l'indium elle
tout à l'heure je veux bien vous donner
acte que vous n'êtes pas raciste mais
est-ce que vous ne flambent et s p cs
que leurs glaives les vivats parce que
m'associer pas exclusivement à débattre
de ce sujet de savoir si je suis aussi
je ne suis pas raciste
j'ai dit que je n'étais ni raciste ni
facile ni extrémiste n'allons pas passer
je pense une heure ou une heure à des
blessures se succédèrent je l'espère
mais c'est quand même et que je n'allais
pas ramené pour crime de racine sur le
bûcher pour me régler n'est ce pas pour
jeu de calmer je ne sais quel les
colères de jeunes tchèques et les dieux
sur le pen sans le pen rester calme ces
gens même si calme c'est quand même sur
ce terrain-là que vous avez fait votre
père c'est vrai donc il n'est pas vrai
c'est totalement faux
mais ces boules il affirme m il fume pas
d'accord du tout je joue d'abord je vous
chie mihara m que genesis et
politiquement car depuis déjà trente ans
que que j'étais député j'ai même été
chef de groupe parlementaire leaders de
groupes parlementaires que j'ai été élu
élus et que je fais de la politique
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps que sans
doute monsieur virieu vous ne faites du
journalisme j'appelle les
téléspectateurs ont besoin effectivement
dans l'heure de vérité de savoir quelles
sont vos réactions personnelles face à
ce que sur les textes que vous citez
monsieur servan-schreiber
vous avez cité deux textes qui sont ceux
d'auteurs connus journaliste confrères
notoire et à qui vous pouvez demander
raison de leurs affirmations et vit dans
le sable s'est faite dans la mesure et
nous allons le voir où un certain nombre
de gens sont vos compagnons de route et
je suis sûr que vous n'êtes pas un homme
à renier vos amis sûrement pas je le
sais donc dans ce cas il m'importe déjà
voir avec leurs qualités et avec leurs
défauts
je ne me crois pas je ne suis pas
totalitaire et je ne demande pas qu'il
soit au garde à vous devant moi ils ont
leur liberté intellectuelle
et pourtant dans le cas de la rue verte
et intellectuel par exemple certains
d'entre eux écrit bhl international de
l'assassinât était composé
essentiellement de juifs le 16 octobre
ça a été un discours de monsieur romain
mary qui je crois a été dans votre
comité de soutien aux présidentielles de
80 est ce que vous êtes ou non en
désaccord avec cette affirmé encore une
fois demandé à monsieur romain mary ce
qu'ils pensent les moins chères aux
marines et assure même comité directeur
du cni et il assume les responsabilités
de ces affirmations et vous ne pouvez
pas me demander en toute occasion
en prenant des extraits de journaux de
discours de quiconque de me dire
monsieur le pen
êtes vous d'accord avec cela et vous
n'êtes pas vous pas d'accord avec cela
cela me rappelle les procès de
l'acquisition c'est une inquisition
politique et je si j'ai à répondre et je
le ferai très volontiers de mes écrits
de mézague de mes positions je n'ai pas
à juger des tiers sur un plateau de
télévision
ça me paraît tout de même une méthode
étonnant g
et qui ressemble fort au terrorisme
politique terrorisme élégant je le
reconnais et et feutrée mais terrorisme
quand même je compte insiste quand même
sur cette citation parce que cette
journée du 16 octobre 1983 qui était
tellement tendu mais vivement l'ensemble
des organisations de droite dans une
journée qui s'appelait amitié française
était je crois en présence de votre part
vous y est devenu il y avait un stand de
votre parti seulement vous avez donc
participer de manière tout à fait
anonyme mais pas plus que ricard à la
fête de l'humanité et monsieur rythmes
africains n'ont pas que des propositions
mardi
je suis des organisateurs de cette
réunion à laquelle je ne participais en
effet que par la location d'un stand
voilà la question l'instant mais un
certain nombre enfin en tout cas une de
ces organisations à la suite de ce qui
s'est dit lors de cette journée s'est
désolidarisé de ce qu'il s'était dit
j'ai constaté je crois que le l'unir le
front national ne s'est pas désolidarisé
que de ce qui avait été dit lors de
cette journée vous permettez moi
simplement de citer également quelque
chose qui personnellement m'a paru
tellement choquant que j'aimerais bien
avoir votre réaction personnelle autre
bombe celle d'anvers plus exactement une
grenade jetée distraitement par un
palestinien sur un groupe d'adolescents
juifs progéniture en balade des
diamantaires d'anvers or son auteur
monsieur alain renaut secrète a été
secrétaire général du front national de
78 à 80 candidats du front national dans
le 16ème en 77
donc là aussi ce n'est pas vous mais
est-ce que si je reprochais et comme
cela vous arrive vous reprocher à
monsieur georges marchais par exemple
pour citer un quidam les déclarations et
des agissements d'autres membres du
parti communiste ce jeu il me semble que
cet amalgame là ne vous est pas
complètement étranger je condamne cette
déclaration tant dans son fond que dans
sa forme
alors pourquoi avez vous accepté des
gens comme cela près de huy m'écouter
alors là je ne suis pas encore fois je
ne sais pas adam à quelle occasion
la personne que vous parlez a fait cette
rédaction d'un article à propos des
effets calmants un avis en temps et au
lieu d'en kaki apparu dans quel journal
je n'ai pas la citation exacte du
journal mais je vous la retrouverez ben
je crois que je crois savoir qu'il
s'agit d'un journal qui n'est pas un
journal du front national et je crois
savoir que quand monsieur troisième sur
renault a écrit cette phrase il n'était
plus au front national
brooks et dans le militant mais bon
alors ils et elles n'étaient plus il
n'était plus au front national
à l'époque où il a écrit ça et par
conséquent je ne je c'est un peu comme
dans le loup et l'agneau de la fontaine
je ne suis pas responsable
avant ni après n'est ce pas mais non
même toujours pendant qu'ils sont là oui
mais je le prends un exemple vous avez
eu par exemple comme candidat aux
élections et comme membre du front
national des gens comme pierre bousquet
qui était un ancien ss et qu'il restait
9 ans trésorier du front national vous
avez eu également comme candidat marc
feret dixon qui a été qui est défenseur
de parti nazi et c'est pour ça que son
parti la fanmi été interdite et est
votre candidat aux élections de 78 la
même façon monsieur hubert colère que
vous avez comme candidat dans la 8e
circonscription dans des aux élections
de 73 avait été préalablement donc vous
aviez pu en juger condamner en 69 pour
incitation à la haine raciale
donc est-ce que cet ensemble de
relations que vous établissez avec des
gens qui sont autour de vous ne peux pas
accréditer comme vous le disiez une
partie de l'image dont vous vous
plaignez tout à l'heure et sociales ciel
la crédite c'était à mon avis de manière
erronée est fausse car ces gens là n'ont
9e monsieur bousquet a peut-être eu les
responsabilités que vous dites il a
peut-être été un ancien ss mais moi je
suis de ceux qui sont pour la
réconciliation des français et qui ne
vint en trente ans quarante ans après la
guerre ne s'intéresse qu'à un seul fait
de savoir s'ils veulent servir leur pays
c'est cela qui m'intéresse voyez vous
j'essaye de rassembler les hommes et je
ne mets pas la manière de servir leur
pays et de donner dans un antisémitisme
tout à fait je ne crois pas que ce soit
le cas des deux jeunes
prenons un exemple vous avez connu amis
proches monsieur françois brigneau wii
qui publie le journal présent vivre
dignement et qui fait partie ont été
condamnés en 79 pour incitation à la
haine raciale
avec comme attendu à encourager les
lecteurs à penser que les juifs sont
incapables d'agir ou de participer à la
politique du pays comme un citoyen
normal et qui sont les auteurs de
machination occultes écoutez moi je je
trouve que cette manière de faire tout à
fait détestable
parce que je pense que c'est cette
acquisition méticuleuse qui est peu
pourrait susciter des réactions de
racisme parce que nous sommes dans un
pays libre où les gens jugent selon le
lieu dans le cadre de la liberté que
leur assurent les lois et il semblerait
qu'il y est une précaution tout à fait
particulière qui protégea les juifs
moi je considère les juifs comme des
citoyens comme les autres mais pas comme
des citoyens supérieurement protégés ils
ne le sont pas plus que ne le sont les
bretons ou d'autres et on finirait par
croire mais servan-schreiber qu'il en
est ainsi et qu'il y aurait en quelque
sorte deux catégories de français serre
dont certains seraient légitimes comme
un diable également mieux protégés que
les ondes
certains le pensent aussi pour les
étrangers je suis personnellement de
ceux qui pensent que dans notre pays
s'il doit y avoir une protection
supérieure elle doit être à l'égard des
français alors vous considère
effectivement donc que les juifs ne sont
pas des français mais pas du tout qui
vous a dit cela ce n'est pas vrai j'ai
pas du tout dit ça écoutez vous me
faites là procès d'attention vous me
faites un procès d' anglais n'est ce pas
non plus ne parlons plus de
d'antisémitisme pour l'instant mais
seulement peut-être de violence j'ai là
un rapport sur lequel j'aime avoir votre
votre avis pour savoir si les faits sont
exacts ou non du commissaire principal
d'alger en 1957 le procès le pen ne
savez pas vous m'avez pas averti je
pensais que monsieur servan-schreiber et
elle a raison de ses compétences
économiques et il m'a persuadé que c'est
un procureur de l'antiracisme certes au
rafale et ex-champion de lundi via lens
ce rapport déclare c'était le
commissaire principal gil que lors de
l'arrestation d'un algérien yahiaoui
abdennour lors de son arrestation deux
fils électriques furent reliés aux lobes
de ses oreilles et le lieutenant le pen
lui même faisait fonctionner une magnéto
à manivelle à l'aide de laquelle il lui
envoyer des décharges électriques dans
le corps en présence de ce même officier
le jeune yaya wii fut frappée avec un
air de boeuf est attaché nu sur un
banquier poignets liés et du zinc jt de
force une certaine quantité d'eau je
vous passe le reste 90 minutes là c'est
scandaleux
bon quand ce général c'est ce monsieur
gilles n'a jamais témoigné de cela ou at
il témoigné de sa g et ecopy d' ce
scandale c'est une provocation policière
c'est une question est celui publié
quels débuts blier n'est publié oui deux
reprises premièrement 1962 dans un
journal qui s'appelle vérité liberté
muñoz in love real député tortionnaires
étaient les cahiers d'information sur la
guerre d'algérie dirigée par un homme
qui a une réputation intègre et monsieur
pierre vidal naquet oh mon dieu
et ce journal n'a jamais était n'a
jamais été attaqué par mais encore une
fois le fait de ne pas attaquer une
diffamation ou un mensonge ne constitue
pas pour autant une vérité vous attaquer
alors si vous voulez écouter
moi je constate que vous vous servez
d'un rapport de police ce qui
généralement ne se fait pas dans un
milieu politique
un pôle un milieu politique et une
tribune de ce niveau je suis scandalisé
que vous utilisiez de telles méthodes en
rappelant des faits sur lesquels je suis
prêt à parler personnellement quand je
vais vous dire j'étais député en 1956
avec mon camarade de marquer je crois
clostermann nous avons quitté notre
siège de député pour aller en algérie
nous battre avec les gens du contingent
et et les rappeler pour leur montrer
notre solidarité
j'étais dans une division aéroportée
dans un régiment parachutiste qui était
le premier régiment étranger de
parachutistes
nous avons reçu une mission mme amon
unités cette mission était donné par le
gouvernement socialiste de monsieur guy
mollet et elle était de protéger la
population française contre une
offensive terroriste de grande envergure
lancée par les fellagas qui posait dans
les rues d'alger
des bombes qui tuer tous les jours des
femmes et des enfants
et cette offensive terroriste visait le
gouvernement doit être brisé elle a été
brisée
ce qui a donné l'occasion aux alliés du
des fellaghas les communistes et et et
leurs amis de lancer contre l'armée
française
une campagne de désinformation et de
dénigrement
j'ai servi en algérie j'en suis fier
avec honneur et j'ai été décoré de la
croix de la valeur militaire
j'ai introduit comme député en rentrant
un une proposition de résolution
demandant que pour effacer les injures
qui avait été fait
alarme aéroportée dans son combat pour
le pays est aux ordres du gouvernement
alors qu'elle soit admise à défiler le
14 juillet
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement la division
aéroportée à défiler dans son
intégralité le 14 juillet 1957 recevant
ainsi l'hommage de la nation
je n'en dirai pas plus sur des faits qui
remontent à 27 ans mais les hommes qui
ont fait la guerre
save as his la guerre en fait n'est ce
pas et je crois que personne ne peut et
en tous les cas pas ceux qui n'ont
jamais fait peut venir réclamer des
comptes à sur la violence de la guerre
sur les nécessaires obligations imposées
par la hiérarchie militaire et politique
du temps nécessaire obligation je vous
remercie terminé svp d'autres questions
une question de politique étrangère à la
place du président de la république
actuel monsieur le pen que feriez-vous
de l'armée française à beyrouth et au
tchad
en l'état actuel de la situation et
après les pertes que nous avons subies
je ne laisserai pas notre corps
expéditionnaire de beyrouth dans la
situation d'être encerclés au capturé
par les innombrables ennemis bien que
nous les fréquentions paraît-il a dit le
président de la république dans son
allocution d'hier soir je prendrai donc
au minimum les précautions que des
alliés autrement puissant que nous ont
pris en l'occurrence des amis
cain mettant leurs marines à l'abri sur
leur porte avions ou sur leurs bateaux
de guerre
je ferai au moins cela tout de suite et
sur le tchad c'est une question qui s'en
doutait et est trop longue à exposer ici
mais je pense que je prendrai toutes
précautions utiles pour que nos soldats
la vie de nos soldats soient protégés et
que nous réservions je le souhaite de
tout mon coeur nos capacités
d'intervention aux pays étrangers et en
particulier aux pays africains qui se
sont résolument est toujours déclaré ami
de la france
il ya une certaine gêne je vous la vous
à savoir que les parachutistes français
protègent au tchad le gouvernement de
hissène habré l'assassin du commandant
gallopin est votre avis fallait-il
envoyé le les forces françaises libres
la politique gouvernementale française
me par est équivoque sur le plan
international et qui vote parce qu'elle
elle semble s'opposer aux menées
hégémonique de l'urss en approuvant les
oeuvres au missile la plantation des
euromissiles en europe
en approuvant aussi en faisant des
opérations militaires jeu je note au
passage que la gauche qui est pacifiste
quand elle est dans l'opposition et est
toujours militariste quand elle est au
pouvoir et en ce qui me concerne
ailleurs participé à trois guerres je
rappelle que ces trois guerres ont été
déclenchées est menée par la gauche
n'est ce pas mais malheureusement ce
sont très souvent les militants et les
soldats de droite qui meurt bon j'en
aurais je considère que cette politique
a été aventuriste est en tous les cas
très largement nous comment dirais-je
polluée par le fait que l'on est admis
au gouvernement français et je répète
mon terme quatre généraux soviétiques en
la personne de quatre ministres
communistes c'est la définition de
lénine que j'applique à ceux ci lénine
avait dit tout communiste doit être un
bon tchékistes c'est à dire un homme du
kgb aujourd'hui c'est l'équivalent par
conséquent ne veut pas que messieurs
fiterman et ses amis puissent croire
qu'ils ne sont pas de bons communiste et
s'ils sont de bons communiste c'est
qu'ils sont de bons kg beast et je ne
comprends pas que le président de la
république qui n'est pas obligé de les
prendre dans sa majorité face à la fois
là
politique que l'on sait en europe et au
liban et au tchad et une politique
exactement inverse quand il s'agit de
mettre des communistes au pouvoir en
france et en même temps sur le plan
international en afrique centrale et en
afrique en amérique centrale
c'est le pen nous allons prendre on
continuer sur ce terrain avec albert du
roy qui viennent nous rejoindre
maintenant pour ce troisième quart
d'heure alors monsieur du roi va nous
faire le fascisme je pense parce qu'on
en aura comme ça vu les trois grands
axes en quelque sorte de ce qui vous
intéresse
malheureusement le pas ce qui t
intéresse le pays juste après l'édition
c'est en vérité sans de l'émission de
numéros pas faire un procès d'intention
à monsieur il se dit roy c'est ce que
vous venez de faire mettez dans une
obligation ennuyeuse où je parle de ce
que vous dites
et dans ce cas vous avez caricaturé à
l'avant ce que je vais faire
ou alors je ne le fait pas et on aura
l'impression que je sais jay d'un
dilemme monsieur non je peux faire ce
que je veux d'accord d'accord et nous
sommes bien d'accord
bon alors avant d'aborder quelques
thèmes qui n'ont pas encore été abordés
des thèmes économiques et des thèmes de
politique étrangère notamment
je souhaiterais avoir quelques
éclaircissements sur quelques sujets qui
ont déjà été abordées ça c'est le
programme du front national brochure du
front national exprime dans ce qui est
dedans vous engage alors je voudrais
simplement une explication c'est pas du
tout polémique toujours et comprendre
front national donc le mot nation est
très important la nation et la
communauté de langue d'intérêt de race
de souvenirs de culture où l'homme
s'épanouit alors la nation française et
la communauté de langue ça veut dire que
des alsaciens qui parlait pas français
ne seraient pas des nationaux d'intérêt
un français qui investirait sa fortune à
l'étranger par national de race vous
avez dit à l'heure les dom tom ce sont
des français
la même race de souvenirs ceux qui
étaient ou dans la résistance ou dans la
collaboration n'ont pas les mêmes
souvenirs n'ont pas fait la même guerre
font pas partie de la même nation je ne
comprends pas très bien cette phrase
vous pensez vous que la nation ce n'est
pas un ensemble de communautés a si bien
sûr solitaire je veux dire c'est en
majorité c'est la dcri c'est une
définition absolument classique de la
nation elle n'a rien de personnel au
front national c'est à dire que cette
nation peut être faite de
quantité de minorité oui mais je ne le
souhaiterais pas je ne souhaiterais pas
qu'elle devienne un nouveau liban
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais
si on souhaitait aussi effectivement
nous avons un pays qui a milan il a un
certain nombre de caractéristiques et
interne certains visages majoritaire
mais ils comportent des minorités aussi
bien les minorités culturel que
linguistique ethnique et jusqu'ici elles
ont vécu en harmonie et si je suis
attentif à ne point se laisser constitué
des minorités étrangères dans notre pays
c'est justement pour préserver ce que
j'appellerais le le plus grand commun
dénominateur
c'est à dire ceux qui tient ensemble les
français ou le plus petit commun
diviseur si vous voulez alors il ya un
slogan qui se retrouve dans certains de
vos meetings qui est fabricant français
avec des français oui c'est une en
quelque sorte c'est une riposte aux
slogans communiste qu'il y fabriquons
français alors nous disons fabricant
français oui mais faisons le avec des
français cela veut dire très clairement
parce que toutes les affiches et toutes
les formules vous le savez mais posé la
question avant on avait posé ses
remarques doivent être synthétique
oui oui j'ai l'esprit vif débat
c'est bien je ne me suis pas trompé bon
c'est vrai dire que quand il ya crise
dans un pays en particulier grave crise
de l'emploi et qu'il y a des des
millions de chômeurs de croix deux
millions et demi peut être même un peu
plus
si l'on écarte les camouflages
gouvernementaux et bien et est qu il y a
6 millions d'immigrés nous disons que
l'emploi doit être réservée en priorité
aux français et que si les immigrés
doivent partir pour leur laisser
ceci est dans le fond conforme à
l'intérêt national de la france et des
français et même conforme à une justice
supérieure donc de les immigrés se sont
tous les étrangers non ça dépend ça ça
dépend dans quel secteur il travaille il
y à des étrangers dont nous pouvons
souhaiter la présence mais il est
évident aujourd'hui en particulier dans
les secteurs et les différences entre le
ce compte dont on peut souhaiter la
présence et ceux dont on ne peut pas
souhaiter à cause de luttes il y aurait
qualité pour notre pays
ceux qui travaillent ils peuvent
je pense qu'en effet il faudrait
commencer par organiser le retour de
ceux qui ne travaillent pas de ceux qui
sont entrés clandestinement dans notre
pays et donc beaucoup ne sont dans notre
pays que des assistés sociaux et j'ai
dit et je répète il y a suffisamment de
crèches d'écoles d'hôpitaux dans notre
pays si il était réservé à ceux qui les
payent c'est à dire en français
malheureusement et il est en train de
s'habituer dans notre pays un véritable
quart monde n'est ce pas de gens
misérables plus misérable que les
étrangers qui souvent ne se donne que la
peine de pousser la porte de notre pays
pour heaven mais un jeu c'est pas un
citoyen des etats-unis qui serait
chômeurs en france il doit partir aussi
chômeurs assistés en france bien sûr que
oui
il a par ses services et est ce que la
france n'a pas actuellement les moyens
de nourrir ni d'entretenir les chômeurs
étrangers ça me parait marocain en
parfaite situation légale régulière en
france et qui aurait du travail lui ne
doit pas partir parce qu'ils n'ont pas
du tout pourquoi si ce travail peut être
occupé par un français je pense que l'on
peut parfaitement demandé à ce marocain
qui rentre chez lui il n'a jamais même
quand le patronat
et quand le gouvernement deux mythes des
années 60 ont sollicité à mon avis à
tort des étrangers de venir dans notre
pays
il n'a jamais été entendu mais jamais
qu'ils étaient des immigrants au sens où
le souhaitait des pays comme les
etats-unis ou le canada
ils ont toujours été considérés comme
des travailleurs temporaires et il est
évident que quand la raison qui les
faisait venir s'éteignait il devait
rentrer chez eux
celle inverse qui s'est produit non
seulement ils se sont maintenus mais
encore des millions d'autres sont venus
les rejoindre qui ne sont d'ailleurs que
en quelque sorte l'avant garde
2 comment dirais-je 2 millions et de
dizaines de millions d'autres permettez
moi je ne fais pas d'habitude
oui mais je vais vous répondre je
voulais vous faire une citation ou deux
citations si vous le permettez sur ce
sujet car elles ne sont pas français ce
sont les seules que je vais vous faire
monsieur ezzeddine mestiri dans la croix
récemment a écrit l'occident a raison de
s'inquiéter car les affamés pourrait
aussi avoir l'idée et le droit pourquoi
pas de venir chercher en europe ou aux
états unis
une nourriture une santé un travail
cette immigration ne serait ni
clandestine ni pacifique ni fraternelle
le monsieur julie traitait récemment
d'ailleurs dans un éditorial
exactement le même thème mais monsieur
boumédiène a écrit avant sa mort un jour
des millions d'hommes quitteront les
parties méridionales pauvres du monde
pour faire irruption dans les espaces
relativement accessible de l'hémisphère
nord à la recherche de leur propre
survie
voilà monsieur du roi ce que je veux
dire dans mon heure de vérité qui est
beaucoup plus important que ce dont nous
avons parlé jusqu'aujourd'hui il y a à
une menace grave de voir les deux
hégémonie l'hégémonie soviétique connus
mais aussi l'hégémonie de nantes à à
l'explosion démographique du tiers-monde
et en particulier au monde islamo arabe
qui actuellement pénètre notre pays qui
progressivement sont en train de le
coloniser et je m'honore et le front
national s'honore d'avoir été la
première formation depuis dix ans a
essayé d'avertir les français de ce
danger mortel
évidemment beaucoup plus ressentie dans
les milieux populaires que dans les
milieux bourgeois je vous l'accordé
j'aurais voulu vous interrogé aussi sur
le fait mais je vais passer sur cette
question parce qu'on n'a pas le temps là
de répondre à tous sur le fait que la
théorie que vous avez exposé à l'égard
des étrangers en france est tout à fait
contradictoire avec les règles du marché
commun la communauté européenne ou alors
vous ne l'appliqué pas aurait au pays de
la communauté européenne est évident et
la suisse ne fait pas partie de la
communauté vous l'appliquez mener la
suisse pourquoi parce qu'il ya des
travailleurs suisses qui se travaille en
france mais je pense que ce dont la
turquie est membre de l'otan vous avez
été là je pense que voyez vous je suis
monsieur du roi un homme de bon sens et
c'est à dire que j'apprends que
j'applique en quelque sorte une
hiérarchie des sentiments et des
directions
j'aime mieux mes filles que mes cousines
mes cousines que mes voisines mais
voisines que des inconnus et des
inconnus des ennemis par conséquent j'ai
mieux les français c'est mon droit
bonbons j'aime mieux les européens
ensuite
et puis ensuite j'ai mieux les
occidentaux et puis j'aime mieux dans
les autres pays du monde
ceux qui sont les alliés et ceux qui
aiment la
ça me paraît un bon critère et puis je
trouve qu'avec ça nous avons déjà
beaucoup de responsabilités et que si
nous si nous assumons celle là ce sera
déjà très bien
je voudrais aborder un autre sujet vous
venez de l'évoquer a très rapidement en
parlant d'un du péril démographique dans
votre position sur l'avortement
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est si votre
position s'explique justement par ces
raisons démographiques le péril
démographique il faut faire des enfants
en france où s'explique par une raison
morale condamnation morale de
l'avortement
monsieur du roi pour les deux parce que
je considère que la légalisation de
l'avortement n'est ce pas a été dans
notre pays une régression de plusieurs
siècles et peut-être de plusieurs
millénaires
car les romains avant même le
christianisme avait noté qu'un france
conceptus c'est à dire que l'enfant
conçu et est réputé nés chaque fois
qu'il s'agissait de son intérêt et je ne
reconnais pour ma part moralement pas le
droit de tuer l'avenir dans la personne
des enfants mais cela se conjugue avec
une préoccupation fondamentale et qui
touche à la politique familiale qui
aurait dû être celle de nos
gouvernements qui aurait dû si gouverner
c'est prévoir être prévoyant dans ce
domaine
alors que depuis 15 ans et plus
spécialement depuis deux ans et demi on
voit une politique hostile à la famille
en tous les cas qui ne n'encourage pas
les français à faire face à leurs
responsabilités fondamentales et sans
doute à la finalité la plus indiscutable
de l'homme sur la terre c'est à dire de
transmettre le flambeau de la vie il
faut faire des enfants ça c'est la
raison démographique on ne n'empêche pas
la vie c'est la raison morale
vous êtes hostile à la contraception
également non je suis pas hostile à la
contraception qui étaient d'une nature
tout à fait différente car en effet elle
ne touche pas à la vie de l'enfant
mais pour les raisons mais je
qualifierais qu'au moins cette liberté
de ne pas concevoir soit largement
contrebalancée par une propagande
nataliste fait par l'état et une
information du public et singulièrement
des femmes françaises sur les nécessités
vitales pour notre pays de remplacer les
générations qui s'en vont faute de quoi
nous deviendrons un territoire de
colonisation et nous serons le vivre que
nous avons laissé sera progressivement
occupé par les vagues dont parlait tout
à l'heure les deux maghrébins célèbres
dont j'ai cité les noms vous étiez
partisans de l'algérie française
celui ci l'avait été réalisée
aujourd'hui aurait combien d'électeurs
ce n'est pas ce qui m'inquiète j'ai dit
à la tribune de l'assemblée nationale
si on ne fait pas l'algérie française
nous aurons la france algérienne
j'ai hélas c'était dans ce domaine aussi
bons prophètes si j'ose dire
mais la conception que j'avais je veux
bien briser n'ont pas n'ont pas le droit
de vote non mais j'avais dit avant
d'exposer avec la blessure est liée en
1956 les algériens auraient eu je veux
dire l'exposé puisque j'ai même présenté
la candidature d'un arabe à à paris
comme députés ce qui est une belle
preuve de racisme vous en conviendrez
alors j'ai dit comment il s'agissait de
monsieur ahmed djebbour qui a été
ensuite élu député d'alger la conception
que j'avais c'est que je pensais que les
nations qui n'aurait pas une grande
dimension géopolitique ne jouerait plus
de rôle à l'échelon du monde et je
pensais qu'il fallait à la france cette
dimension est que l'algérie et le sahara
la lui donner à la france est d'ailleurs
à l'europe et que la conception je le
dis un impérialiste en quelque sorte du
rôle de la france
expansionniste aurait pu s'appuyer
justement qu'est impérialistes privilège
à gérer oui impérialisme oui oui oui
pourquoi pas oui oui je pensais que la
france et l'europe pouvait légitimement
compte tenu de leur rôle dans l'histoire
du monde et les responsabilités qu'elle
avait assumé de deux avantages pour les
populations du monde qu'elle pouvait
porter de la culture qui était la sienne
pouvait très légitimement essayer de
jouer un grand rôle mondial et dès qu'il
est qu'il fallait pour cela que
l'algérie soit français je dois vous
rappeler tout de même que ce n'est pas
une invention de jean-marie le pen
car comme j'ai défendu l'algérie
française je ne faisait qu'appliquer les
zélés comment dirais-je des prises de
positions d'aborder tous les
gouvernements français jusqu alors y
compris celle de monsieur mitterrand y
compris celle de monsieur world
je pense y compris celle du général de
gaulle qui a là d'une façon plutôt
solennelle à alger à mostaganem dire la
même chose simplement moi j'étais fidèle
non seulement au passé de la france mais
j'étais fidèle à une forme d' avenir et
je pensais qu'avec les juifs avec les
européens d'algérie avec les arabes et
les kabyles d'algérie on pouvait faire
une communauté française tournée vers le
monde tourner vers l'afrique
tourné en effet vers une conquête
pacifique du monde c'est à dire que les
seules hégémonisme que vous ne tolérez
passé le soviétique et celui de thierry
et j'aimerais qu'ils savent c'est ça
tout à fait sûr les mêmes méthodes et à
ce propos je voudrais me dire combien
j'ai été personnellement choqué de voir
que monsieur cheysson et écru de voir
associer en une minute de silence
les députés européens à la mort de
monsieur andropov chef du de l'hégémonie
soviétique et de l'urss et je voudrais
puisque dans ce domaine les les silences
sont souvent plus pesant que les
discours
moi aussi me lever à mon tour pour tenir
une minute de silence ou une quelques
instants de silence au moins pour en
mémoire de tous ceux qui sont tombés des
dizaines de millions d'hommes tombés
dans le monde sous la dictature
communiste et d'avoir une pensée
fraternelle à l'égard des millions
d'hommes qui sont dans les camps et au
goulag
moi je suis journaliste je continue à
poser mes questions si vous le voulez
bien
j'aurais aborder les thèmes économiques
alors je voudrais poser une question
particulièrement sur les
restructurations industrielles
monsieur je vais vous répondre
immédiatement merci je vous pose la
question le problème des immigrés étant
supposé par hypothèse régler le
problème du chômage étant supposé par
hypothèse réglé par le départ des
immigrés tout dans les problèmes
économiques de la france ne serait pas
pour autant résolu font un exemple
un exemple entre d'autres les chantiers
navals il ya très peu de travailleurs
immigrés d'un chantier naval ils sont en
crise grave
il ya un an car plus de 20 ans qui sont
en crise grave où je pose la question
d'accord il ya plus de vingt ans
responsable le de rien dans cette partie
heures mais comment résolvez vous ce
problème là étant entendu que la halle
départ des immigrés n'arrange pas tout
bien écoutez je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
solution au problème de la crise ni avec
monsieur mauroy ni demain avec monsieur
chirac ou avec monsieur bart si nous
restons dans le cadre d'une économie
socialiste
je crois que c'est essentiellement le
socialisme qui chez nous aggrave la
crise et empêche sa solution la preuve
c'est que dans tous les autres pays
occidentaux qui n'ont pas qui ne sont
pas en régime socialiste
ils sont en train de résoudre les
problèmes de la crise il faut à mon sens
tourné le dos socialisme tourner le dos
à la politique que l'on mène dans ce
pays depuis plus de vingt ans car je
voudrais rappeler que en effet le
libéral le libéralisme avancé n'était
somme toute qu'une forme déguisée du
socialisme le plus éculé que c'est sous
monsieur giscard d'estaing que nous
avons franchi la frontière qu'il avait
lui même fixé à 40 % de prélèvement du
pnb
n'est ce pas quand vous séparer non mais
c'est vrai je vais laisser moite exposer
mon idée aussi que pour séparer un pays
socialiste date d'une économie libérale
n'est ce pas or monsieur giscard
d'estaing a pris le pays avec 35% de pnb
en 74 il a abandonné en 1982 prime est
obligatoire fallu qu'elle soit en orissa
sur la richesse et sa de psa
c'est ça non le prélèvement sur la dirso
le grain ce que les citoyens sur ces
singes et ce pays est la part de ça
c'est bien ce que je dis c'est ça les
prélèvements et temps du pnb
n'est ce pas c'est cela et il l'a
quittée à 42% c'est à dire que c'est en
fait en 79 que la france est passée
selon les critères même de monsieur
giscard d'estaing en économie sociale et
nous n'avons bien sûr que de faire mieux
si on n'a fait que croître et embellir
la question oui la question question bon
sur les restructurations oui je vais y
revenir parce que si nous n'avions pas
tout ça tout ça ne règle pas le problème
des grands secteurs industriels français
qui ont vieilli weekly on vieillit
surtout dans les secteurs où l'état
d'accord dans l'état s'est mêlé
directement très bien mais alors que
fait-on pour demain ce n'est pas
l'abandon du socialisme tel que vous le
décrivez sireix de la sidérurgie est
viable sidérurgie française telle
qu'elle existe et viable dans son état
actuel dans son état actuel
si tout ce socialisme que vous décrivez
est abandonné écoutez je pense qu'il va
mais oui mais parfaitement je penche là
je veux dire pourquoi parce que le
socialisme à la fois giscardien
chiraquiens et et mitterrand desk si
vous voulez le socialiste de la vème
république a abouti à paralyser ce pays
c'est une bureaucratie de plus en plus
pesant
n'est ce pas il ya eu de plus en plus de
fonctionnaires le domaine le secteur
public n'a cessé de s'agrandir
il n'a cessé de devenir de moins en
moins productifs et corrélativement les
charges et les impôts donc cessé
d'augmenter au point de décourager
totalement l'initiative à 1 pointe est
d'ailleurs que contrairement à l'analyse
faite par michel chirac
je ne crois pas du tout qu'il s'agisse
d'une incapacité de gouverner l'économie
de la part des socialistes mais d'une
volonté délibérée de détruire les
structures de production de liberté de
détruire l'appareil capitaliste pur en
et enfin la question enfin oui mais
tandis comme ceux ci et échanger
quand la confiance est restaurée quand
ceux qui travaillent et qui en ont
ras-le-bol monsieur du roi du que les
charles ne cesse d'augmenter que le fisc
ne cesse de les tracasseries de porter
sur leurs dos d une des gens qui ne
travaillent pas et qui en quelque sorte
passé moi l'expression vivent à leurs
crochets quand cela verront leurs
efforts récompensés mais quand les
entreprises pourront faire du profit
quand on pourra distribuer à
l'actionnariat et à l'actionnariat que
je souhaite le plus l'actionnariat
populaire de l'argent enfin tout sera
changée car quand les syndicats auront
été
remis en quelque sorte à leur place qui
n'est pas qui ne consiste pas à faire la
révolution comme le croit la cgt et la
cfdt
nous aurions une tout autre nous aurons
une tout autre orientation
et à partir de ce moment là je crois que
nous pouvons relancer l'économie est
évident que c'est très difficile à dire
ici en quelques minutes et je souhaite
dans d'autres circonstances pouvoir le
dire non mais j'en connais pas ce
monsieur servan-schreiber me parlerait
exclusivement de l'antisémitisme alors
je répondrais j'aurais souhaité traiter
cette question vient vous dire la vérité
c'est que l'industrie dont vous parlez
celle des chantiers navals
elle a été assassinée littéralement
comme beaucoup d'autres dans notre pays
par les syndicats et en particulier par
la cgt selon la technique qui est la
suivante quand une affaire commence à
mal marché qu'il faudrait dégraisser
qu'il faudrait qu el sadat n'est ce pas
au moment où il faudrait qu'elles
s'adaptent au moment où il devrait
remplacer le personnel par des
technologies modernes et en particulier
souvent par des robots que fait la cgt
elles déclenchent la grève et l accule
cette entreprise qui est déjà au bord de
la faillite à la faillite
elle occupe les locaux et ensuite elle
ruine ses entreprises ça a été vrai pour
le france ça a été vrai pour la marine
marchande française
ça a été vrai pour les ports et docks
français ça a été vrai pour les pour les
chantiers navals
ça a été vrai pour un certain nombre
d'industries automobile et ce en quelque
sorte c'est de cet effet maléfique d'un
syndicalisme révolutionnaire avec
l'utilisation d'une main d'oeuvre
étrangère sous qualifiés a conduit en
effet chez nous l'industrie lourde et
l'industrie semis lourde à ne pas faire
pendant la période de la prospérité
les nécessaires mutations technologiques
qu'elle aurait dû accomplir et il est
évidemment extrêmement difficile pour ne
pas dire impossible de le réaliser
maintenant et la politique de monsieur
mauroy ne constitue derrière de jolies
phrases et des formules nouvelles que
cautère sur jambe de bois ni lui ni
personne ne pourra dans ce pays
faire une politique d'expansion
économique sans tourner le dos
résolument au socialisme bureaucratique
qui est entrain al'inverse 2
conduire notre pays progressivement à la
démocratie populaire
je crois que c'est clair monsieur le pen
on nous retournons asvp d'autres
questions oui dans beaucoup d'élections
partielles vous appeler à voter au
deuxième tour pour le rpr où l'udf alors
que vous vilipendez à longueur de
meetings et chirac et giscard n'est ce
pas contradictoire
pas du tout c'est que je fais là aussi
une hiérarchie entre les directions et
les répulsion il est bien évident que si
je reconnais et ici j'ai dénoncé pendant
des années la complicité et la
complaisance de l'opposition
parlementaire alors majorité à l'égard
de la gauche et à l'égard du communisme
si j'ai dit qu'elle faisait avec les
voix de la droite la politique de la
gauche qui me semblait une escroquerie
politique et aimer morale dans un
certain sens il n'en reste pas moins que
le rpr et l'udf se situe dans un choix
de société qui est un choix de société
de liberté alors que les communistes
surtout mais aussi les socialistes quand
ils sont alliés avec eux conduisent le
pays vers une forme progressive n'est ce
pas de limitation des libertés on le
voit bien dans le domaine du travail
dans le domaine de l'enseignement dans
le domaine de la presse dans beaucoup
d'autres domaines et provoque un
affaiblissement de l'économie qui va
jusqu'à la pénurie que l'on connaît dans
les pays où dans le fond le socialisme a
abouti si j'ose dire
autre question vous parlez souvent
monsieur le pen de morale et de valeurs
traditionnelles pour vous
l'homosexualité est elle un délit
l'homosexualité n'est pas un délit mais
elle ne doit pas être non plus une
valeur privilégiée car de toute évidence
elle constitue relativement une anomalie
biologique et sociale et dans ces
conditions je crois que eux ils ne faut
pas occuper le devant du terrain ni
faire du prosélytisme se croit qu'il y à
là non seulement une question de bon
sens mais aussi une question de bon goût
monsieur le pen que pense monsieur le
pen de la position d'yves montand et
d'yves montand lui même qui est émigrés
italiens
là le fait que yves montand c'est un
immigré italien ne change rien à la
chose
notre candidat oser
hexion d'aulnay sous bois était le fils
d'un immigré italien et le responsable
de l'ile-de-france au front national est
un petit fils d'immigrés italiens et je
peux vous crois pouvoir vous dire qu'ils
se trouvent tout à fait à l'aise chez
nous yves montand a fait un retour sur
lui-même retour spectaculaire
il a en effet découvert le communisme
trente ans après moi et il a évidemment
un peu la ferveur et l'ardeur de pau
lieu qui n'est ce pas pour détruire ce
qu'ils avaient adoré je lui en fais pas
grief au contraire parce que le discours
qu'il a tenu me paraît être un discours
de bon sens plein de talent d'ailleurs
yves montand jouant yves montand c'est
du très bon spectacle et qui va dans le
très bon sens moi je suis de ceux qui
ouvrent les bras à tous les français à
tous les françaises même s'ils avaient
des opinions contraires aux miennes à
partir du moment où somme toute ils
s'aperçoivent de la vérité j'ai noté
dans le discours de monsieur d'yves
montand une réserve touchante au front
national
mais comme je le sais sur le bon chemin
sur la bonne voie je ne doute pas somme
toute un jour de lui voir exprimer une
opinion favorable aux idées que je
défends alors encore deux questions jean
louis de sun oui que comptez-vous faire
des anciens harkis au mais les anciens
harkis sont des français et il y en ait
un certain il y en a un certain nombre
dans le front national est partout où je
passe je fais des réunions publiques je
peux vous dire que je reçois à la fois
les doléances quelquefois très chagriné
de ces français par le sang donné n'est
ce pas sinon par le sang reçu qui me
disent qu'elles l'elorn la tristesse de
leurs situations souvent tenus à l'écart
par les français qui les prennent pour
des étrangers est tenue pour
collaborateurs par des étrangers qui se
permettent de les insulter dans leur
propre pays
il va sans dire que pour moi les harkis
sont des français à part entière
quelle est la différence monsieur le pen
entre le front national et le parti des
forces nouvelles et pourquoi y at il eu
scission
il n'y a jamais eu scission parce qu'il
n'y a jamais eu accord et que tout le
monde sait dans le petit monde de la
politique de droite que le parti des
forces nouvelles a toujours eu une
attitude hostile aussi bien à jean marie
le pen qu'à la politique qu'il défend
des et les liens qui ont uni
notamment lors des étés visible lors des
élections diverses
ce mouvement aux partis de la majorité
et singulièrement au rpr qui a
d'ailleurs accepté au bout de quelques
années que les chefs de ce groupuscule
étudiants deviennent des responsables
dans son propre parti montre bien toute
la différence qui a entre un parti qui
ne prend ses consignes nulle part et
dans le fond une courroie de
transmission comme une autre d'un parti
politique de l'opposition comme vous
voulez de répondre brièvement aussi le
pen on peut peut-être donner une
dernière question svp
oui pour en revenir au fn est ce que
vous ferez liste commune pour les
élections européennes c'est beaucoup sur
le fait fait un bond non nous ne serons
pas liste commune une liste commune avec
aucun mouvement
la liste du front national sera front
national je la dirigerait et elle sera
cependant ouverte un certain nombre de
personnalités politiques ou sportives ou
culturelles ou universitaires qui de
ceux ci afin de montrer que pour nous
les élections européennes sont une étape
une étape sur la voie du redressement de
notre pays sur la voie de la renaissance
de la france et la défense supérieur des
intérêts français
monsieur le pen nous arrivons au terme
de cette émission il y at il quelque
chose que vous auriez vous lui direz que
vous n'avez pas pu dire vous estimez les
empêcher de dire ce soit non je n'ai pas
été empêchés de le dire mais j'aurais
voulu dire un certain nombre de choses
sur l'état de l'esprit public français
et sur le fait qu' on sous estime à mon
avis gravement le degré de tension à
l'égard par exemple de la fiscalité du
de la charge fiscale à l'égard de la
persécution fiscale qui s'exerce sur les
catégories sociales qui travaillent le
plus qui prennent le plus de risques
et cela il me paraît très méritée en
effet tout un débat vous allez je vous
rappelle très brièvement quels étaient
les grands axes des campagnes du front
national s'est en effet l'immigration
c'était l'insécurité dont nous avons
très peu parlé c'était le chômage dont
nous avons aussi peu parlé c'était aussi
le la marque 6 à sion du pays
et puis le laxisme général cette
décadence cette crise à la fois morale
et spirituelle que connaît notre pays
et sans la résolution de laquelle il n'y
aura pas de redressement ni de
renaissance de la france et je crois
très profondément que beaucoup de
français espère dans des formations
nouvelles et dans des hommes nouveaux et
pense que il ya eu changement un
changement dans une direction qu'ils
estiment mauvaise
ils souhaitent un changement dans une
autre direction mais ils se disent
comment l'ancienne majorité
pourrait-elle faire demain ce qu'elle
n'a su ni pu ou ni voulu faire hier dans
la prospérité et je crois qu'elle a
confiance dans des hommes comme moi qui
ne se penche pas sur le peuple mais qui
sortent du peuple pour exprimer à la
fois ses aspirations à la fois ses
espérances et peut-être construire avec
elle un avenir de lives et de liberté et
un avenir d'espoir merci monsieur le pen
prochain rendez vous le lundi 5 mars
invités valéry giscard d'estaing bonsoir
[Musique]